Story the eight news now investigators
first broke with Vanessa Murphy now
joining us live in studio with more well
problems inside Nevada state
and prison leaders are Head to Head
during this hunger strike
Joseph Quinones is one of nearly 30
inmates refusing to eat at Ely State
Prison since December 1st he calls this
hunger strike a peaceful protest to
demand better conditions like sufficient
Medical Care and food and for complaints
against officers to be taken seriously
Quinones is currently serving time for
burglary and robbery damn prison's
prison and I accept the consequences for
my action didn't they and it's it's not
that we're crying about being in prison
it's the fact that the way they're
treating using he claims he hasn't been
outdoors in about a month and he's in
solitary confinement the practice
advocacy groups like return strong argue
against after constant pleas for help to
prison leaders return strong is now
asking the state to bring in outside
parties like human rights organizations
to provide oversight these are things
that have gone on checks for years and
they've only gotten worse during covet
these were a lot of these were issues
pre-pandemic and they continue to be and
they continue to get worse and worse and
this is in many ways the the canary in
the coal mine from resignations of the
prison's director after a convicted
murderer escaped and a warden after a
riot which the department tried to
downplay until we exposed it to inmate
suicides and murders there have been
major failures inside Nevada prisons
this hunger strike just the latest we've
uncovered the Department of Correction
says it's working to resolve the issue
and monitoring the health and weight of
inmates like Quinones this fight is not
for me this fight is for the community
this fights for the prison system
the Department of Corrections has
continuously said Staffing is a major
issue the pay rate for correctional
officers compared to other law
enforcement agencies is low